m
[Musique]
une grande surface dans la banlieue du
mans
[Musique]
un rayon d'importance les fleurs
la reine de tout c'est la rose
cette année la tendance est au jaune à
l'orangé et au bicolore
ici l'on vient pour soi ou pour d'autres
mais toujours pour le plaisir
[Musique]
ces fleurs viennent d'un entrepôt situé
à quelques kilomètres celui de la
société big aux fleurs
jean bigot 77 ans est le patron de
l'entreprise familiale
[Musique]
toutes ces roses ont la même histoire
elles sont parties il ya quelques heures
d'afrique
elle arrive juste du kenya
au bout des chaînes elles ont fait
combien de kilomètres elles ont fait
très exactement
8175 km et vous vous préférez ce sont
les quais laisser cette variété
tropicale à base de rôles
lorsque nous sommes arrivés au kenya en
2001 c'était la préférée des gazelles il
a fallu convaincre vos protections
autour de nos rosiers cette vérité là
était davantage manger par la pratique
at-elle dit que toutes les autres alors
c'est par patrice
larrose préférés de jean bigot et des
gazelles vient de la région du lac de
naivasha une carte postale africaine est
aujourd'hui l'un des principaux lieux de
culture de roses au monde
une chance pour le kenya mais également
de nombreuses controverses les fleurs du
bonheur serait elle aussi les fleurs du
mal voyage au pays des roses
[Musique]
cap sur la vallée du rift une grande
dépression qui s'étend de l'ethiopie
liés à la tanzanie à 2500 mètres
d'altitude
un jardin d'éden le poumon de
l'agriculture et de l'horticulture
kényane
[Musique]
jean bigot nous emmène visiter son
exploitation
cela fait maintenant sept ans qu'il a
délocalisé sa production de rose
la bonne attitude pour les roses oui oui
oui c'est important c'est la lumière
d'altitude faites en sorte qu'il y a
en général un temps un petit peu couvert
avec une lumière ce qui est de 12 heures
chaque jour
des conditions climatiques idéales pour
la culture des fleurs
[Musique]
après des années de prospection un peu
partout dans le monde jean bigot a
choisi de s'installer en afrique de
l'est
[Musique]
cette vallée est tout près de l'équateur
donc une luminosité permanente d'autre
part il y à de l'eau dans le sous sol
lui a beaucoup d'eau kenya ya de l'eau
partout il suffit d'avoir les moyens il
suffit d'investir c'est un pays de
cocagne le kenya
le pays de cocagne c'est la vallée de
naivasha la vallée des roses
il y a dix ans il n'y avait rien ici
aujourd'hui une soixantaine
d'exploitation se sont regroupés autour
du lac
pour les kenyans cette province est
synonyme d' el dorado les roses c'est un
emploi et un salaire pour échapper à la
misère
ils viennent des zones les plus pauvres
du pays et sont 50000 à travailler dans
les immenses serres de la région
[Musique]
pointage par empreinte digitale
bleu de travail de rigueur
vestiaires impeccable
ici sont appliquées les standards de
production les plus modernes en afrique
même impression pour la chaîne de
conditionnement où s'activent des
centaines d'ouvriers essentiellement des
femmes
robotisation
traçabilité logistique
le progrès technique au service de la
rose du kenya
ici et chaque jour jean bigot et son
fils jean-philippe expédiés entre 200000
et 300 mille fleurs fraîchement coupées
larose n'échappe pas à la globalisation
alors sait combien une rose comme ça le
rock band et combien actuellement le
prix moyen de vente tout clientèle
comprend du 17 vers ie8
et c'est vrai là il est nettement
inférieur à celui d'une rose produite en
europe 11 en europe je pense que c'est
de l'ordre de 25 à 30 centimes
production annuelle moyenne 10 et 30 à
40% d'économie le climat n'explique pas
tout selon l'entrepreneur pas d'autre
solution que de s'installer au kenya
c'était indispensable
on allait droit dans le mur on a pau et
plus produire raisonnablement on ne
pouvaient plus vendre les roses tout
simplement
sens des affaires impératifs de gestion
l'activité de jean bigot ne se résume
pourtant pas qu'à cela pour lui la fleur
est avant tout un art
sélection de variétés nouvelle mise en
pots préparations des greffons taillé en
biseau plantations puis cueillette
patients ces observations sont les
maîtres mots du métier même à 8000 km de
la france on suit avec attention les
tendances et les attentes du marché
et chez bigot les 1200 salariés seraient
mieux traités que dans le reste du
secteur
l'industrie n'a pas bonne réputation
les conditions de travail sont décriés
les salaires souvent très bas
même devant leur patron les employés ne
mâchent pas leurs mots comment ça se
passe le travail
le travail se passe très bien mais tout
est très cher en dehors des fermes
alors on demande des augmentations de
salaires pour les employés
alors
puisque vous êtes là les patrons oui
alors elle demande elle dit que les
salaires sont pas assez élevés or voilà
c'est dit c'est je pense que évidemment
ça sera un discours qu'on entendra
régulièrement ce qui me semble à peu
près normal ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
que on a donné des augmentations
substantielles
l'année dernière ce qui n'a pas été le
cas partout depuis combien de temps
êtes-vous dans l'entreprise depuis
quatre ans vous avez vu des changements
les salaires ont ils été augmenté oui
beaucoup
comme cette femme les salariés de bigot
fleurs gagne environ 70 euros par mois 2
euros par jour c'est peut-être très peu
mais plus que la moyenne des salaires du
secteur agricole
au kenya un employé de l'industrie
horticole fait figure de privilégiés
josphat garcia directeur des ressources
humaines ventes les bonnes pratiques au
sein du groupe
[Musique]
manille
souriez mesdemoiselles souriez
ce débat vous ne mangez pas avec des
cuillères
nous nous occupons du recrutement et des
licenciements des employés mais nous
avons surtout une vraie responsabilité
c'est tout ce qui touche au social pour
les salariés et pour qu'ils se sentent à
l'aise on prend soin d'eux on leur
fournit et en sécurité sociale faire
et à entendre monsieur le drh ce ne
serait pas le cas partout
pour certains des salariés du secteur
horticole ne dispose d'aucun moyen de
transport ils n'ont pas de lieu pour se
restaurer certains n'ont même pas accès
à l'eau potable
vous savez et j'en reviens à notre ferme
ici nous fournissons tout cela et nous
respectons les réglementations l'eau
dans l'industrie horticole la rose a
aussi ses épines que se passe-t-il donc
dans les autres exploitations
nous comprenons vite que nombre de
salariés sont beaucoup moins bien lotis
ailleurs
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres de chez bigot des
centaines d'employés attendent chaque
jour les bus qui les emmène vers les
fermes
pour pas de contrat un travail précaire
et vous comment ça se passe votre
travail bien et votre salaire ah non ça
ça ne va pas
certains ici gagne un dollar par jour un
dollar par jour et pourquoi pays d'ici
peu
à cause du manque de travail nous sommes
tellement nombreux et les opportunités
d'embauché sont rares alors on n'a pas
le choix ce boulot est à prendre ou à
laisser
qui est journalier ici vous pouvez lever
la main
tous les employés ici sont temporaires
bien sûr 70 % des employés et si vous
tomber enceinte vous êtes renvoyé de la
ferme
ne veulent pas de femmes enceintes non
ils n'en veulent pas pourquoi masquer
les jeux sont pas efficaces dans leur
travail exactement
comment vit-on avec un dollar par jour
nous cherchons à approcher les
conditions de vie des employés des roses
pour les trouver il faut se rendre dans
ces bidonvilles perché sur les hauteurs
des collines autour du lac naivasha
dans la foulée du boom économique
ils ont poussé aussi vite que les fleurs
ici tout le monde travaille dans
l'industrie horticole et les salaires
restent trop maigre pour pouvoir
s'extraire de la pauvreté
janet par exemple elle fait partie de
ces milliers de femmes qui ont quitté
l'ouest du kenya pour une vie meilleure
le faible salaire que je gagne je ne me
permet pas de faire vivre ma famille
alors après le travail je tiens ce petit
commerce ici à vendre ses haricots des
ligues et quelques banal
son petit commerce un complément vital
pour janet son salaire dans l'industrie
de la rose ne lui suffit pas elle
travaille 6 jours par semaine pour 55
euros par mois
[Musique]
janet nous emmène chez elle elle vit
avec ses quatre enfants
sa maison un abris de tôle sans eau ni
électricité
c'est ici que j'habite c'est ma maison
et voici ma famille voilà petroni 14 ans
dawson est en ce moment à l'école il a
13 ans
brian 10 ans et margaret nos ventes
mon mari est décédé il ya quelques
années je suis veuve
ici c'est mon lit moi et mon plus jeune
enfant nous dormons ici et petroni comme
elle est déjà trop grande pour tenir
dans le lit elle dort par terre
c'est comme cela que j'arrange ma maison
la nuit elle n'a pas de matelas elle
dort juste sur ce tas de sacs et de
couvertures
qu'est ce que vous voyez comme à venir
pour vos enfants
je pense que comme j'ai beaucoup
souffert moi en tant que maire je pense
que si je peux les éduquer mes enfants
pourraient avoir une meilleure éducation
à ces du collège au lycée voire jusqu'à
l'université si j'y arrive
ils peuvent avoir un meilleur emploi
plutôt que de travailler dans des fermes
horticoles
pétronille je pense qu'elle pourrait
devenir pilote peut-être a pas eu
l'autre j'ai des floridiens bébé
pilotes c'est ce que tu veux devenir
tout sauf les roses
pourquoi janet ne soit elle pas le même
avenir pour sa fille
que se passe-t-il donc dans ces immenses
aire protégée par des barbelés
quelles sont exactement les conditions
de travail
impossible d'y voir de plus près nous ne
sommes pas les bienvenus personne
n'accepte de nous ouvrir ses portes
personne sauf jean bigot et craig hilton
kényan blanc
directeur général de l'une des
principales fermes il finit par nous
recevoir mais à ses conditions
tant que vous ne filmez pas je n'ai pas
de problème avec la caméra
attend que quoi tant que vous ne filmez
palais certes
mais si on filme pas à l'intérieur des
serres est ce qu'on peut au moins filmé
à l'extérieur non je n'ai pas la
permission pour cela je le crains désolé
donc on ne peut pas filmer ni à
l'intérieur ni à l'extérieur
non
craig hilton veut rester maître de la
situation mais il est trahi par son
micro
après je reprendrai ses hommes dans ma
voiture et je les emmènerai voir le
point de vue sur les fermes je veux
m'assurer qu'il ne fût nous mourrons
rien d'autre
feghoul tonnes ne veut nous montrer
qu'une seule chose les efforts de son
entreprise pour préserver
l'environnement
l'interview tourne vite à la visite d'un
musée floral
après maintes explications détaillées
nous serons absolument tout sur la
végétation locale
mais rien sur le sujet qui nous
intéresse vraiment les conditions de
travail des employés de la ferme
et
[Musique]
ça c'est l'eau que nous récupérons et
maintenant est ce que vous vous rappelez
cette eau très sale maintenant nous
avons une eau comme celle ci elle est
absolument pur c'est comme un ruisseau
de montagne je vais vous montrer
lors rejetée par les fermes
ce n'est pas un hasard si craig hilton a
choisi de nous en parler c'est l'une des
grandes controverses des roses au kenya
c'est aussi le combat de canotiers noé
douglas gatchatcha
les deux hommes vivent près du lac et
milite dans des associations de
protection de l'environnement
pour eux aucun doute les fermes
horticoles sont directement responsables
de la baisse du niveau du lac
là où nous nous trouvons c'était à
l'origine un terrain entièrement
recouvert par les eaux
le lag s'avançait jusqu aux arbres que
vous voyez là bas tu
es maintenant comme vous pouvez le
constater on peut il marcher
l'eau s'est retirée sur presque 100 m
en l'espace d'environ 10 ans
cela veut dire que la baisse du niveau
de l'eau a été vraiment très rapide
kennedy glace nous emmène constater de
plus près l'impact des cultures de rose
le lac naivasha est tout simplement en
train de disparaître
[Musique]
pour les oiseaux et les hippopotames la
menace est bien réelle
démonstration de l'étendue des dégâts en
plein milieu du lac il n'y a plus assez
de fonds pour continuer à naviguer
les flamands roses peuvent marcher ici
nous pensons que le niveau de l'eau est
encore en train de baisser
très bientôt tout ce qui nous entoure
sur un lac asséché
surtout quand on compare à ce que le lac
était à l'origine en fait le niveau
baisse à cause de l'importante
consommation d'eau probablement à cause
des fermes horticoles il y a des tonnes
de pompe qui extrait l'eau du lac pour
irriguer les exploitations
selon douglas gatchatcha le lac a baissé
de moitié en quelques années
vous voyez mon bâton il est sec
regardez
c'est tout ce qui reste oui c'est tout
ce qui reste ça ne sert à rien d'essayer
de faire marcher le moteur du bateau
et par exemple quelle était la
profondeur du lac à l'époque c'était
aussi profond que ce bâton
les cause de l'assèchement du lac les
pompes des exploitations horticoles
[Musique]
pour les voir il faut suivre les canaux
d'irrigation creusé par les fermes
autour du lac
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
les pompes tournent à plein régime
et c'est pour qu'elle fonctionne 7 jours
sur 7 24 heures sur 24 ouais
les fermes sont sous bonne garde des
hommes surveillent les pompes mieux vaut
laisser à douglas le soin de poser les
questions à notre place
cette pompe à quoi elle sert
pour les plantations de fleurs
oui d'accord et elle fonctionne tous les
jours oui
[Musique]
des pompes qui puisse quotidiennement
les eaux de naivasha une population
accrue due au développement des fermes
horticoles
un bouleversement pour la région et son
environnement
parmi les victimes il y a les pêcheurs
ils subissent directement les
conséquences du boom de la rose au kenya
certains évoquent même les impacts des
rejets chimiques sur le produit de leur
pêche
david kg ancien pêcheur préside une
association de protection de
l'environnement il nous emmène à la
rencontre
mais encore faut-il les convaincre de
nous parler à la vue de deux
journalistes la méfiance est l'art
si nous disons quelque chose qui risque
de limiter l'entr'aide et tout le
système de coopération nous risquons de
nous faire beaucoup d'ennemis
et nous ne voulons surtout pas d'ennemis
pour faire notre travail
leurs réactions montrent qu'ils ne
peuvent pas tout dire à propos du lac
pourquoi
parce qu'ils craignent que le
gouvernement ne leur retire leur licence
l'atmosphère fini par se détendre et ses
looks à san mames le chef des pêcheurs
qui va nous raconter combien les temps
sont durs aujourd'hui
le tilapia un poisson que l'on trouve
dans les grands lacs de l'est de
l'afrique
aujourd'hui il est en voie de
disparition
ça c'est les espèces de poissons que
nous pêchons dans le lac on en trouve
désormais davantage que le tilapia vous
savez il y a quelques années les espèces
que l'on pêchait c'était le tilapia
mais maintenant on trouve surtout des
carpes ici
et lorsque le lac sera asséchée alors
tous les poissons auront disparu
autre témoin de la pollution du lac ce
tapis de plantes sur lequel doivent
naviguer aujourd'hui les pêcheurs du
jamais vu sur les rives du lac naivasha
avant l'industrie horticole
nous n'avions pas ces jacinthe d'eau
mais comme ces plantes aquatiques se
porte très bien dans les eaux polluées
il y en a dans les systèmes d'épuration
d'eau des fermes autour du lac
et maintenant elles descendent jusque
dans le lac
elle empêche la navigation comme vous le
voyez les pêcheurs doivent se battre
pour naviguer elles détruisent aussi les
filets
leur multiplication est vraiment due à
la contamination
dans certains endroits du dac où ces
plantes se développent
c'est parce que l'eau est soit pollué
soit en train de se réchauffer
comme les autres horticulteurs de la
région
jean bigot a massivement recours aux
engrais et aux pesticides pour la
culture de ces roses
les serres sont mises en quarantaine le
temps de traiter les fleurs
[Musique]
équipements de protection nécessaires à
l'utilisation de ces produits dangereux
mais selon les syndicats les pesticides
auraient un impact direct sur la santé
des employés des fermes horticoles
[Musique]
un peu l'écart des cerfs des entrepôts
sont spécialement affectés à la
préparation et à l'injection des engrais
chimiques
jake tapp quelle est la consommation
mensuelle d'engrais
en tout environ
56 à 60 tonnes
par mois oui par mois 100 tonnes de
fertilisants qui forcément non mais
c'est quelque chose imprimée des
colonnes et connaissez vous exactement
l'agriculture ce qu'ils utilisent dans
les champs de maïs fait les fêtes le
différentiel patron c'est exactement ce
qu une plante va pouvoir exporter comme
éléments nutritifs et on lui donne
exactement ce qu'elle a besoin ni plus
ni moins il n'y a pas de pollution et
c'est important aussi que le personnel
qui procède aux traitements soient
suivis médicalement c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles on a mis en
place une clinique permanente cenap
non c'est pas le cas partout non
les dangers des produits chimiques il en
est beaucoup question à naivasha
une ville passée de 20 milles à 120
mille habitants en 10 ans
quel est le véritable impact sur la
santé humaine nous sommes allés voir du
côté des cliniques une seule nous a
ouvert ses portes nous avons rendez vous
avec le docteur isaac loup bazille il
n'a aucun doute sur les conséquences des
pesticides
il est bien placé pour en parler il a
lui-même travaillé pendant dix ans comme
médecin dans une ferme horticole
beaucoup de ces patients travail dans la
rose
elles vont affecter par des produits
chimiques non
tous les employés qui travaillent dans
les fermes respirent les produits
chimiques qui sont diffusés
et petit à petit cela affecte vos
organes respiratoires et ça peut même
provoquer des cancers
les quatre cancers sont très probable et
cela affaiblit le système immunitaire
des employés n'étaient pas là et ces
entreprises elles disent qu'elles
dépensent beaucoup d'argent dans la
médecine
si elle constate qu'un employé malade
elle lui demande généralement d'écrire
une lettre de démission
pour raisons médicales
et pourquoi faut-il cela parce que
l'employé affecté n'est pas productif
des dangers pour la santé des pratiques
sociales discutable des atteintes à
l'environnement au kenya la rose fasciné
fait débat à la fois les affaires elle
se porte comme un charme
anaérobie tous les deux ans les
horticulteurs se retrouve au principal
salon de la fleur en afrique outillage
produits chimiques construction de
serres technologies d'irrigation
isabelle henin française installée elle
aussi au kenya nous emmène pour une
visite guidée mais là encore c'est la
loi du silence
est ce que tu veux parler
ca c
les producteurs ont perdu leurs clients
dentelle grande surface parce que tel
journal disait que quel employé n'avait
avaient été licenciés ou l'état de ne
portait pas de masque etc sans que ce
soit vraiment vérifier donc tout le
monde un petit peu peur de vous
messieurs une crainte qui nous
accompagnera jusqu'à la fin de notre
voyage au pays des fleurs
avant de partir nous rendons une
dernière visite à jean bigot
les roses sont sur le point de quitter
l'exploitation
ici point de méfiance plutôt une volonté
de nous convaincre reste dans un premier
temps à l'eau pendant environ six à
douze heures avant d'être ensuite mises
dans des cartons comme les cartons que
vous voyez ici
avant d'être acheminés vers l'aéroport
de nairobi la ménagère achètera ses
fleurs là dans deux à trois jours
paradoxalement une fleur produite en
afrique va nécessiter 700 et 1000 moins
de co2 qu'une fleurs produites dans les
mêmes conditions en europe parce qu en
europe il faut chauffer et éclairer ces
roses et en fait des études
internationales l'ont trouvé très
clairement une rose malgré qu'elle ait
fait 8000 kilomètres en avion vous êtes
moins d'empreintes co2 qu'une rose
produite en europe
tous les arbres du monde ventes sont les
bienvenus
42 jours pour cultiver une rose
48 heures pour l'expédier
ici commence le long voyage des fleurs
du kenya
je
dans deux jours elles brilleront sur les
étals de france et du monde entier elles
survivront encore une petite semaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]